[Music]
here's what you need to keep up with
when it comes to the Kardashian everyone
is so critical of sites while Kylie
Jenner has been busy ringing in 22
living her best life in Italy with
boyfriend Travis Scott and their one
your daughter's stormy Khloe has been
having her own hot girls summer the 35
year old reality star posted a stunning
bikini shot from a recent tropical
vacation on Sunday along with the
caption this summer I have been focused
on me me from within mind body soul Coco
followed up the post with several suite
photos showing her playing on the beach
with one-year-old daughter true I'm
really just enjoying my life and my time
with my baby and family the posts come
days after Khloe's ex-boyfriend French
Montana opened up about their 2014
relationship to Haute Living calling
their love real and adding that he and
Chloe will always be friends
quote when the love with like that it's
always going to be like that friendship
after a relationship is something that's
real hard to do and I'm glad we've been
able to do it and speaking of keeping in
touch to work all night what are you
doing I am gonna go and be in this music
video with Paris for one of her new
songs no way yeah she asked you yes I
know Kim's getting candid about her
lasting friendship with Paris Hilton and
a new promo for the upcoming 17th season
of Keeping Up with the Kardashians in it
the mom of four credits Paris with
helping her launch her now massive
career as she prepares to pay it forward
by appearing in the heiress's best
friends music video I really would want
to do anything for her she literally
gave me a career and I like totally
acknowledged that and trying to get
everything done before the met and
everything done before the baby comes
no I know and I would drop it for her
I understand as much to me to be loyal
to people it will go a long way of
course Kim and parrots were besties long
before the Kardashians had a reality
show well we've known each other since
were little girls
we always love each other Kim even
worked for the 38 year old socialite
appearing in a 2003 episode of The
Simple Life and it's her closet
organizer I love this closet so but
what's going on with that is if I ever
go to India alpha the two drifted apart
once Kardashian started finding fame but
they rekindled their friendship in 2012
and it remained closed ever since
but ha it's nice to see my friends doing
so while I love it